c'est dame nature on peut bien les gars
du moment où le cpo parfois pâle avec un
moment sont peu mieux ses marines et
n'importe de cro magnon ni d'aucun cas
pas communiquer avec un moment c'est pas
comme une baleine aux coûts ils vont
mettre et permet aux mollahs c'est la
suisse qui a bien ri milot et ce qu'il
compte l'impact court et n'a plus
d'autres capables avec un roman
quand j'ai confondu avec un roman marie
tête à faire c'est tout décale ventre et
ça fait des trucs se remonter un peu la
chemise c'est quelqu'un qui est très
décolleté
la maison est tout à la madrague à
lamballe la maison est à l'envers laisse
les soirs le baragouin du sur la table
laissez le bar sortie on les madelinots
acadien qu'elle me croire